Charles Kingsford Smith: Australia's Aviation
Hero
This episode is made possible byt the realistic
online game WAR THUNDER.
Check out this game through the link in the
description below!
Go through that our link and you not only
support this show but you you get a free premium
tank or aircraft and three days of premium
time as a bonus!
And let's get into it...
During the late 19th century, a German man
named Otto Lilienthal achieved some of the
first successful, repeated flights using gliders.
Regrettably, he suffered a crash on August
9, 1896, and died the next day.
Reportedly, his last words were "Sacrifices
must be made!"
This was a mentality shared by all the pioneers
of flight.
During the inception of aviation, there were
few professions out there more dangerous.
A quick look at all the pilots from the first
decades of flight and you will find very few
of them who got to see retirement after a
long and successful career.
If you'll pardon the cliché, these men and
women were made of sterner stuff than the
rest.
One of these daredevils was Australian Charles
Kingsford Smith.
He discovered his passion for flying during
World War I and, for the rest of his life,
always looked for new opportunities to soar
through the skies.
In the process, he set a number of world firsts
such as the first trans-Pacific flight from
the United States to Australia.
Unfortunately, like many of his peers, Kingsford
Smith's career ended in tragedy and his final
resting place remains, to this day, a mystery.
Early Days
Born on February 9, 1897, in Hamilton, a suburb
of Brisbane, Australia, Charles Edward Kingsford
Smith was the seventh child of a banker named
William Charles Smith and Catherine Mary,
née Kingsford.
Although the family originally went simply
by Smith, they added the surname Kingsford
in 1903 when they relocated to Canada.
The move did not last long and, in 1907, the
Kingsford Smiths were back in Australia, but
this time in Sydney.
Charles became known as Smithy, a nickname
he would carry for the rest of his life.
When he was nine years old, Charles almost
drowned at Bondi Beach when he got dragged
out to sea by a rip current.
The young boy struggled to stay afloat, but
eventually lost consciousness.
He was saved just in time by the lifeguard
service which had only recently came into
existence, and was resuscitated by a nurse
who was in the right place at the right time.
Later, during his aviation career, people
said that Kingsford Smith was terrified of
flying over the ocean and would get sick whenever
he did it.
This may have been the genesis of his angst.
As a teenager, Charles enrolled at a technical
school where he studied to become an engineer.
He also joined the Senior Cadets, a military
youth organization.
Service in the War
Image suggestion: Sapper in World War I
After the outbreak of World War I, Kingsford
Smith enlisted in the Australian Imperial
Force in February 1915.
The 18-year-old took part in the Gallipoli
campaign where he served as a sapper with
the 4th Signal Troop, 2nd Division Signal
Company.
He had his second brush with death here.
As he described in a letter to his parents,
he heard some "ping" noises very close to
him.
When he finally reached shelter, Kingsford
Smith noticed that a bullet came so close
to his head that it had frayed the edge of
his cap.
Later, he became a dispatch rider during campaigns
in Egypt and France.
After being promoted to sergeant, Smithy transferred
to the Australian Flying Corps in October
1916.
This is where he got his first taste of flying
and developed a passion that would follow
him for the rest of his life.
He trained in England where he showed immediate
aptitude as a pilot.
He was commissioned as second lieutenant with
the Royal Flying Corps (RFC), the precursor
to the Royal Air Force.
Kingsford Smith was sent to the French front
as part of the No. 23 Squadron.
There, he shot down four enemy aircraft, as
well as launching multiple attacks on ground
targets and balloons.
Inevitably, Smithy was bested in a dogfight
and was shot down himself.
He walked away from the crash, although his
injuries did require amputation of several
toes.
Kingsford Smith received the Military Cross
"for conspicuous gallantry and devotion to
duty".
Because his recuperation would take a long
time, he was allowed to visit his parents
and Australia and, upon returning, was promoted
to Captain and assigned as a flying instructor.
Life after the War
By the time Smithy was fully healed, the war
had ended.
He wasn't sure what he wanted to do with his
life, but he knew that it had to involve flying.
He teamed up with another pilot named Cyril
Maddocks and formed a joy-flight company that
offered pleasure airplane trips throughout
England.
However, the young Smith was already looking
for opportunities that would bring him fame
and fortune.
In 1919, Australian Prime Minister Billy Hughes
announced the Great Air Race.
A prize of £10,000 would be awarded to the
first person who completed a flight from Great
Britain to Australia in under 30 days.
Unsurprisingly, Kingsford Smith wanted to
take part in the race, but he was denied membership
into the Royal Aero Club of Australia (RACA),
and, by default, entry into the competition.
Officials were concerned over Smithy's lack
of navigational experience over the 11,180-mile
route and thought that it would be dangerous
to let him race.
Instead, the prize was claimed by brothers
Sirs Ross and Keith Macpherson Smith.
Although he was not allowed to compete in
the Great Air Race, an idea sprouted in Smithy's
mind.
It was another surefire way to glory: the
first trans-Pacific flight from the United
States to Australia.
Spoiler alert: this would be the feat that
brought him everlasting fame, but now was
not the time.
Kingsford Smith traveled to America to search
for sponsors for his daring escapade but failed
to find any.
He occupied his time with other flying gigs
which included stunt work for a circus and
for Hollywood movies.
However, he saw another pilot die in an accident
and decided that the job was too risky, even
for him.
He returned to Australia in 1921.
Back Home
He might have had it with life as a stunt
pilot, but the experience did not detract
from Smithy's pleasure of flying.
Back home, he started another joy-riding company.
He also became a salaried pilot with the West
Australian Airways.
Started by another RFC veteran, Sir Norman
Brearley, this was the first Australian airline
with a scheduled air service.
In his personal life, Smithy married Thelma
Eileen Hope Corboy in 1923.
By all accounts, it was an unhappy marriage
that only lasted for a few years as Kingsford
Smith was not made for a stable life in one
place.
His biographer Ian Mackersey said that the
aviator's mind was always in the sky, thinking
about the next time when he would be able
to fly again.
When he was on the ground, Kingsford Smith
enjoyed women, booze, and spending his money
almost as fast as he made it.
The Trans-Pacific Flight
Smithy believed there was huge potential for
an airmail service in Australia.
Together with another aviator called Charles
Ulm, he started the Interstate Flying Services,
but found it difficult securing contracts.
To show people that airmail was the future,
the two pilots wanted to perform some demonstration
flights to attract sponsors and investors.
They did a round trip of Australia in a little
over 10 days which garnered plenty of attention.
Sensing an opportunity to secure funding,
Kingsford Smith forgot all about his airmail
business and, instead, once again promoted
his true dream: the trans-Pacific flight.
This time, it worked.
Kingsford Smith not only obtained a grant
from the government of New South Wales, but
also received financial backing from two businessmen:
Myer Department Store founder Sydney Myer
and California oil tycoon George Allan Hancock.
Image suggestion: The Southern Cross
First off, they had to buy a plane.
Smithy and Ulm traveled all the way to America
to find the one they wanted but, bizarrely,
still ended up buying one from another Australian.
Specifically, they purchased a Fokker F.VII
from polar explorer Sir Hubert Wilkins.
It started life as the Detroiter, but Smith
rechristened it the Southern Cross.
The goal was to take off from Oakland, California,
and finish in Australia.
This was not a non-stop flight, so they would
land to refuel two times, the first of which
would be in Hawaii.
Over the previous year, ten pilots had died
attempting just this leg of the trip.
The odds were not in their favor, but the
airmen were determined to carry on.
Image suggestion: The flight team
https://discoveringanzacs.naa.gov.au/browse/gallery/13673
Kingsford Smith had a four-man team.
He was the pilot while Ulm acted as relief
pilot.
On board were also two Americans: James Warner
who was the radio operator and Harry Lyon
who served as navigator.
The foursome took off from Oakland on May
31, 1928.
They reached the island of Kauai to refuel
after an uneventful 27 hours.
From there, they set off on the longest stage
of their journey to Fiji.
To make matters worse, they encountered a
massive lightning storm but, nevertheless,
reached the island of Suva in one piece.
The final stage saw them fly into Brisbane
Airport to a hero's welcome as tens of thousands
of people cheered them on.
After 83 hours and 38 minutes of flying time,
Kingsford Smith and his crew completed the
first ever trans-Pacific flight.
Across the Tasman Sea
Kingsford Smith received a ton of rewards
for his feat, including the Air Force Cross,
an honorary position as squadron leader with
the Royal Australian Air Force and over £20,000
in funding.
Now that the trans-Pacific flight was out
of the way, he could focus again on his more
practical ambition – that of establishing
an airmail company.
Like before, he considered a series of daring
flights to be the best way of showcasing the
viability of such a service.
In August 1928, just a few months after his
journey across the Pacific, Smithy performed
the first non-stop flight across mainland
Australia, taking off from Point Cook near
Melbourne and landing in Perth.
Then, less than a month later, he already
had a new ambition – to be the first to
fly across the Tasman Sea to New Zealand.
Not only would this have been another gratifying
feather in Smithy's aviator cap, but he hoped
that it would also secure an airmail contract
between the two countries.
At the time, achieving the first trans-Tasman
flight was the "next big thing" for many Australian
and New Zealand aviators.
However, in January of that year, two Kiwi
pilots named John Moncrieff and George Hood
disappeared over the sea while attempting
the flight.
No trace of them or their plane, the Aotearoa,
has ever been found.
Kingsford Smith's venture in September 1928
was the first attempt since their disappearance.
Image suggestion: Southern Cross landing in
New Zealand
https://teara.govt.nz/en/photograph/7481/southern-cross-monoplane
He had a crew of four again.
Charles Ulm was by his side as relief pilot
and joining them were radio operator Thomas
McWilliams and navigator Harold Arthur Litchfield.
They boarded the Southern Cross and took off
on September 10.
After a flight of 14 hours and 25 minutes,
they landed at Wigram Airport in Christchurch.
Tens of thousands of people were there to
cheer them on, including students and public
servants who were given the day off for this
momentous occasion.
After the Highs Come the Lows
With another world first under his belt, Kingsford
Smith was the talk of the town once again,
but he would soon find himself involved in
a few controversies with fatal consequences
that had a lasting impact on his reputation.
Now that the trans-Tasman flight was also
out of the way, Kingsford Smith's pragmatic
side started showing again.
In 1929, he intended to fly to England to
purchase four new aircraft for his budding
company.
He took a crew with him aboard the Southern
Cross, but had to make an emergency landing
in the middle of nowhere in Western Australia.
The crew was safe, but the plane was in no
condition to fly, so they patiently waited
to be rescued.
Of course, the disappearance of a hero the
stature of Charles Kingsford Smith prompted
a massive search involving many other pilots.
Among them were two of his friends named Keith
Anderson and Bobby Hitchcock.
They flew aboard the Kookaburra hoping to
spot a sign of the downed airplane.
Unfortunately, they also suffered problems
and crash landed in the Tanami Desert.
While Smithy and his crew would be found and
rescued, these two pilots died of exposure.
Image suggestion: Kookaburra Memorial
It hardly seemed fair to blame Kingsford Smith
for the tragedy, but rumors soon started circling
that the forced landing of the Southern Cross
had been nothing but a publicity stunt.
The media sensed a juicy story and fanned
the flames of controversy.
Some even accused the aviator of purposely
making it harder for search teams to find
them.
That way, the longer they stayed gone, the
more press they received.
The incident became known as the "Coffee Royal
Affair", named so after the black coffee and
brandy drink which the crew of the Southern
Cross purportedly drank while awaiting rescue.
An official inquiry was launched into the
matter and, although Kingsford Smith was exonerated,
his reputation was tarnished in Australia.
Australian National Airways Opens and Closes
Overseas, everyone still loved Smithy so he
climbed into his trusty Southern Cross and
took to the skies for a few more headline-grabbing
flights.
In June 1930, he completed an east-west crossing
of the Atlantic from Ireland to America in
thirty-one-and-a-half hours.
This also meant that he completed a circumnavigation
of the world which he started with his first
trans-Pacific journey.
Later that year, he won an air race from England
to Australia, breaking the speed record while
flying solo.
Alongside Charles Ulm, in 1929 Smithy finally
founded the airline he dreamed of for years,
which was called Australian National Airways.
It commenced operations in January 1930 with
five airplanes with Kingsford Smith himself
flying the Southern Cloud.
The company wasn't around for long.
The airline had to close down following another
landmark moment in the history of aviation,
but one that Kingsford Smith could have certainly
done without – the first airliner to disappear
during a flight.
On March 21, 1931, the Southern Cloud left
Sydney for Melbourne.
Kingsford Smith was not the one flying.
On board were two crewmen and six passengers.
They all perished in a crash in the Snowy
Mountains of New South Wales due to bad weather.
Their final location remained a mystery for
27 years until a hiker named Tom Sonter stumbled
upon the wreckage.
It goes to show that, back then, being a passenger
on an airplane took about as much courage
as being a pioneering aviator.
Image suggestion: Southern Sun crash
https://nla.gov.au/nla.obj-144699765/view
A few months later, the Southern Sun also
crashed while trying to make the first airmail
delivery from Australia to England.
Charles Kingsford Smith spent all his time
and money convincing everyone that flying
was a safe and practical way to transport
mail and people in order to start a successful
airline.
Once he finally launched his company, he showed
them the exact opposite.
Back then, at least, flying was still anything
but safe.
The Journey of the Southern Cross Minor
It seems like almost every other plane that
Kingsford Smith piloted apart from the Southern
Cross was destined for tragedy.
In 1931, he added a new aircraft to his collection:
an Avro Avian Mk.V he dubbed the Southern
Cross Minor.
He wanted to use it to set a new speed record
for the Australia-England flight, but was
unsuccessful.
He sold it a few years later to another aviation
pioneer, British pilot Bill Lancaster.
Image suggestion: Bill and Jessie
https://en.wikipedia.org/wiki/File:Billandchubbie.jpg
Lancaster had a career worthy of mention.
It mirrored that of Kingsford Smith and was
highlighted by triumphs, controversies, and
death.
He also started flying during World War I
and later pursued it as a career.
In 1927, he achieved one of the longest flights
in a small aircraft by journeying from England
to Australia.
He was accompanied by his lover, Jessie "Chubbie"
Miller, who became a successful aviatrix in
her own right.
A few years later, the two were living in
Miami, Florida.
While Lancaster was in Mexico, looking for
work, they brought in a writer named Haden
Clarke to help Miller write her memoirs.
They started an affair and Miller even decided
to leave Lancaster for her new beau.
Upon hearing this, the aviator returned home
and, soon enough, Clarke was found dead from
a gunshot to the head.
Lancaster was charged with murder.
His alibi didn't hold water and he admitted
to forging two suicide notes.
He had recently purchased a revolver and witnesses
heard him say that he will get rid of Clarke.
You would think this would be an open & shut
case, but Lancaster was actually found "not
guilty".
He might have dodged prison, but his reputation
took a big hit and Lancaster became a pariah.
He was desperate to regain just a fraction
of his lost prestige and that is where the
Southern Cross Minor came in.
Lancaster decided to go for the England-South
Africa speed record as that was the in vogue
flight of the day.
He bought the plane from Kingsford Smith and
set off on April 11, 1933.
Everything that could go wrong did.
Lancaster had gotten lost several times and
fell behind schedule.
He was so sleep deprived that officials tried
to detain him when he landed for refueling.
He ignored them and pressed on and crashed
in the Sahara Desert.
Image suggestion: Wreck of the Southern Cross
Minor
Miraculously, the pilot escaped his ordeal
almost unscathed.
He still had a serious problem, though, as
now he was stranded in the middle of the desert
with few supplies.
He waited to be rescued, occasionally firing
off flares, but the rescue never came.
Lancaster died eight days later, on April
20, 1933.
It was almost 30 years until French troops
found his mummified corpse and the wreck of
the Southern Cross Minor.
He had left behind a diary detailing his last
days on Earth which was later published with
Miller's permission.
What's left of the plane sits in the Queensland
Museum.
The Lady Southern Cross and Smithy's Final
Flight
In 1935, Kingsford Smith had a very close
call in the Southern Cross while attempting
the first trans-Tasman airmail flight.
One of the plane's three motors stopped due
to a damaged propeller blade.
The three men aboard the craft only survived
because Smithy's co-pilot, P.G. Taylor, climbed
out of the cockpit and transferred oil from
the dead motor to the others using a suitcase
and a thermos flask.
Kingsford Smith had to dump all the mail and
extra cargo and barely made it back to Sydney.
This was a sign that, perhaps, it was time
to retire the Southern Cross.
Smithy purchased a new plane – a Lockheed
Altair called the Lady Southern Cross.
He sold his famous airplane to the Commonwealth
of Australia so it could be put on display
in a museum.
At first, the new aircraft appeared to be
a worthy replacement.
With it, Kingsford Smith performed the first
eastward flight over the Pacific Ocean, going
from Australia to the United States.
In 1935, he decided to use it in order to
break the England-Australia speed record.
He set off on November 6, 1935.
With Smithy was co-pilot Tommy Pethybridge.
His longtime flying partner, Charles Ulm,
had vanished and, presumably, died a year
prior while flying over the Hawaiian islands.
Image suggestion: Leg of Lady Southern Cross
https://collection.maas.museum/object/141688
Unfortunately, this was a fate the two would
share because the Lady Southern Cross also
disappeared over the ocean.
On November 8, it took off from India and
was headed to Singapore, but was never seen
again.
It is presumed the plane crashed in the Andaman
Sea, off the coast of Burma, killing Charles
Kingsford Smith and his co-pilot, Tommy Pethybridge.
A year and a half after the disappearance,
an undercarriage leg and wheel washed up ashore
on an island and remains the only part ever
recovered from the Lady Southern Cross.
In recent times, filmmaker Damien Lay claimed
in 2009 to have found the wreckage of the
airplane.
His proclamation has been met with much skepticism
from experts and aviation historians.
He has not made the location public and, presumably,
is still trying to raise funds for a recovery
expedition.